SPEAKER 1: Orgyen is an
author and meditation
master in the Dzogchen tradition
of the Tibetan Buddhism.
He is the founder and spiritual
director of the Pristine Mind
Foundation, based
in Marion County.
He studied with Jigmed
Phuntsok Rinpoche,
one of the greatest Dzogchen
master in the 20th century, who
passed away recently.
After completing an ambitious
studies with Jigmed Phuntsok
Rinpoche, he received
his khenpo degree,
which is the highest degree
of Buddhist study and practice
in the Buddhist tradition.
Orgyen currently lives in Bay
Area, travels around world
to give teachings and retreats.
I'm very, very happy that Orgyen
is able to come to Google.
Let's welcome Orgyen
Chowang Rinpoche to Google.
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Thank you
for everyone coming today
to listen in teachings, and
also meditating together.
I very happy to be in Google.
Today, I want to
talk about my book.
Actually, this book I wrote,
you know, almost 10 years,
called "Our Pristine Mind."
This book is a meditation
book, and also how
do you transform human life
through cleaning up your mind.
And then I want to
talk about today,
how do you really live in
vitality, energy, and stress
free in life and each moment.
What is most important
to do in your life?
And then, I'd like to talk
about particularly what
is really human mind is.
A human mind is not
just what you think
and what it
fundamentally is, and how
the human mind has affected
every day of your life.
Then I was, you know,
in last few years--
maybe almost 10 years--
I just worked on one book.
It's a meditation book.
Actually, many years
working this book,
and finally finishing
last year in 2016.
The book is called
"Our Pristine Mind."
It actually really
means, how do you really
release your mind of these
toxic, negative, pollute
experiences.
How do you experience
your true self?
How do you experience your
natural conditioned mind?
And I think really what is
the most important thing
is, really how do you do that?
It is through meditation.
Meditation is like actually
pay attention to your mind.
For example, pay
attention to your mind.
You know, usually our
attention is always conditions,
like always we have 100%
external conditions--
sounds, images,
taste, and everything.
But one place we
don't pay attention,
the only place, the most
important area, is the mind.
Why many people are
stressed, sometimes
feel sad, or anger,
sometimes depressed,
and all these
mental events happen
because the reason
is we don't know
what's going on in our mind.
Many areas we take care of.
We take care of our
business, we take care
our home, even our hair.
You pay attention to you
hair every day, dress--
everything-- but
one place we ignore.
What is that?
Our mind.
If you forget your mind, then
your mind be very complicated.
The reason the mind is
complicated, and mind is upset
and always ups and
downs, is because we
don't know how to fix that.
We don't ever pay
attention to that area--
that particular area.
Meditation means you pay
attention to your mind--
what it's really like.
I think that's really what
it boils down to meditation,
and that's really I want
to talk about today.
For example, let's
say your people
are stressed, angry, anxiety,
or fear, the meditation job is
how to release these things.
How to release these energies.
If you don't release, then you
have to continually experience
that uncomfortable feeling.
The meditation's job
is how to release that.
And that really, really,
means, for example,
let's say you have a house.
Your house you
have 20, 30 years.
You never pay attention.
You never clean up.
You never pay attention
or clean up your house.
You always walk in, but you
always never pay attention.
What's like that house?
Very messy house, yeah?
It's a very, very
uncomfortable place
to live, because you never
clean your mind, and house.
20, 30, 40 Years, we
never clean our mind.
How many times do
you clean your mind?
We clean our bathroom,
kitchen, and any other areas,
but how many times do
you clean your mind?
The number one is
that you need to clean
your mind if we have
fresh, energetic,
and light and experience.
If we don't clean our
mind, the symptoms are--
when people are sad, that's a
result. Your mind is polluted.
When you're sad, it's
because the mind is polluted.
When you have anxiety,
the mind is polluted.
When you have stress,
your mind is polluted.
When you're angry,
If your mind is polluted, your
relationships are polluted,
because if that's fact-- your
relationships and connections--
and that effects everyday
life, because you
look at the world as a
very stressful place.
The reason is your
mind is polluted.
And that's really
the reason meditation
is not just only paying
attention to conditions--
you can fix the conditions.
You can fix your house,
you can get good job,
but your mind, at the same
time, stirs stress, discontent,
bad mood.
If that always happens, then
how do you really fix that?
Number one, the
wonderful news is
that your mind is originally
pristine, but temporarily
polluted.
And then I want to
show today here,
how do you experience
your pristine mind?
Someone says, someone who has
experienced a healthy body,
what's like that?
It feels good, yeah?
When you're sick
so many long years,
and then you feel sometimes, I
feel my healthy body, so good,
it's like myself.
Similarly, if you feel
your pure consciousness--
you feel your clear mind
without anxiety, without fear,
without stress--
the clear mind you
experience, what's that?
That's the most
majestic experience
you've ever felt before.
Very powerful experience.
Then I want to introduce today,
how do you experience that?
Everybody in this
room's mind is pristine,
but there's too pristine,
but right now overcast
mental events.
The thoughts, the emotions,
the beliefs, and the habits
overcast your mind.
The sky is blue--
clean-- but the clouds
made overcast the sky.
Maybe you don't see the sky
because clouds may obscure
[INAUDIBLE] to see the sky.
It's similar.
Similarly, if your
mind is made pristine,
but you cannot access because
there's so much clouds--
mental events like
stress, anger,
fear, all these things there--
you cannot experience your
natural conditioned mind.
Therefore, we always
know how to feel.
We feel our thoughts.
We feel our emotions.
We feel our habits.
But how many people feel
their pristine mind?
Feeling emotions are
not that comfortable.
Feeling thoughts are
It's very awkward.
Why human beings have so
many different facials--
some people sit like this,
some people like that--
because they attach emotions.
If you attach your emotions,
sad has a different expression,
the anger has a
different expression,
the happiness is
but all human beings know
how to attach their emotions,
how to attach their thoughts,
how to attach belief systems,
how to attach their body, but
how do you many people detach--
with their clear
awareness, pristine mind?
I think that's really
our about, and I
want to talk to today about
that's really [INAUDIBLE].
Basically, the message
is how to really
attach yourself without
layers, without fabrication.
And then, let's say
human mind is pristine--
means very clear,
very flawless--
that's really the fundamental
message from the [INAUDIBLE],
master of Dzogchen master.
Then how do you
attach with that?
This is very wonderful way.
If you don't meditate, you never
know your mind is pristine.
You've never meditated.
Even if you've meditated, but
you didn't meditate properly,
you don't know your
mind is pristine.
There are many
different meditations.
Some meditations, as you
know, calm your mind.
That's really the meditation--
the goal is calm your mind.
Some meditations are designed
to have a pristine mind--
pristine awareness.
And then, here we are
talking about a pristine mind
meditation.
Pristine mind
meditation, you do that,
and you can experience
your flawless mind.
Flawless mind.
How do you do that?
What happened?
The reason is, we don't
experience our mind as calm,
pristine--
the reason is, there's
so much mental events.
When mental events
are disappeared,
then you can experience.
As long as there's
clouds in the sky,
you cannot see the blue sky.
That's noise.
When clouds disappear,
then you see the blue sky.
Similarly, as long as
our mind is overcast,
we cannot experience
our fundamental mind,
or pristine mind.
Then when your mind is clear--
when-- because when
your mind is clear,
and because when mental
events disappear,
then when is mental
events disappear?
During the meditation.
I want to talk about
the technique, too.
How do you disappear
your mental events?
If you do these four
steps, your mind is clear.
Your emotions are clear.
Your thoughts are clear.
What is really the technique?
Technique of this meditation
is called [INAUDIBLE].
The meditation master of the--
he says, if you want
to clear your mind,
if you want to enjoy
your pristine mind,
do these four steps.
He says, first,
don't follow past.
Let's say 20 minutes we are
doing meditation, for example.
Don't follow past, don't
anticipate in future.
Stay present moment.
Leave your mind alone.
If your mind is not past, not
future, stay present moment,
and you leave your mind alone,
then what happens internally,
that's meditation.
And that means your
thoughts, emotions, anxiety,
fear everything is dissipated,
because they're conditional.
They cannot survive without
paying attention to the object.
And then thoughts, emotions,
and sadness, anxiety, stress--
everything's disappeared.
When they're disappeared,
what is your experience?
You experience your
awareness without layers,
then you experience
really pristine mind.
The meditation is go into the
pristine mind time to time.
Today I entered
the pristine mind--
I did this meditation technique,
and then my mind is clear,
and then I stayed
there 10 minutes.
I stayed with pristine
mind 10 minutes.
And tomorrow you
repeat the same thing.
Your pristine mind, 10 minutes.
Then over time, you have--
even if you are not
meditating, your mind
is 70% clearer than
normal people's minds.
I think the number
one happiness is--
number one happiness
in this world--
you can tell me
better than that--
when someone's mind
is pristine, that's
the highest quality
happiness in this universe.
You can't tell me
this is much better.
I think when people's mind
is clear and pristine,
everything--
whole entire being is very
comfortable, and very sense
of well-being.
And you have straight
forward of the world.
There's no hindrance there.
If your mind is,
let's say, distorted--
you know, polluted-- then
everything becomes complicated.
Complication comes from when
mind is polluted and distorted.
And that really means, human
beings, what we need like that,
we need enjoy the world.
Since you enjoy the world, you
need to have beautiful mind.
If you have the beautiful mind,
you have to enjoy the world.
But if you have the mind
is not good a quality--
it's distorted-- then you
don't enjoy the world.
Therefore, in order to enjoy
the world, success your work,
connect other people, and
also appreciate everything.
What is really you need?
You need to have clear mind.
Clear mind is key to the
success, effective, work,
and also relationships.
Every day, what is
really key is clear mind.
When you have clear
mind, nothing matters.
You are fearless, and you are
comfortable with yourself.
Your mind is 70% overcast--
let's say 70%.
That means that day you
are not comfortable.
Maybe you're stressed.
You're maybe having anxiety,
and you are uncomfortable.
Let's say that is 70%
overcast your mind.
70%, 80%.
That says, 70% clouds in sky,
that means 70% chance of rain.
70%, 100%, and there's
tremendous clouds in sky,
sometimes there's
100% chance of rain.
Why is there 100%
chance of rain?
Because there's so
many clouds in sky.
Similar, the more
thoughts, emotions
there are, the more in your
mind, your mind is complete.
There is 100%
chance you're upset,
and also 100% chance
you're maybe angry,
or maybe you have
offended someone,
or something happens, because
the mind is too cloudy.
Here is the meditation.
How do you reduce 70%
you mental events.
It's not necessary.
For example, you have a house.
You don't put everything there.
You can clean up time
to time your house.
Similarly, the meditation is
time to time clear your mind.
Therefore, I was talking
to many years here,
and people are meditating, and
then say they do meditation
today or tomorrow.
The next few days, they
have best experiences.
It's not only my doing, but I
train many different people,
like people--
I live in Marin County, and I
go to San Francisco, and Marin,
and also other places--
tech companies-- I went to
Autodesk, some other tech
company I went to,
also I went to schools.
I teach regular people.
They tell me, they say,
oh, I did meditation.
Three, four, one week,
is tremendous benefit,
because meditation means you
are directly working your mind.
You're directly
working your mind.
It means of course impact there.
Therefore I want to talk about
[INAUDIBLE] here, pristine mind
and unconditional happiness.
But I think this is
a very beautiful--
unconditional happiness--
I want to say a few things
unconditional happiness.
Unconditional
happiness is connecting
with the pristine mind.
If your mind is 70%
clear, and 70% are like--
60% are clear, and a
pristine-- definitely,
your happiness no
longer conditional.
What does that mean?
The meaning is, if
your mind is pristine,
definitely your mind is
comfortable without condition.
There's a sense of well-being.
When mind is pristine,
definitely there
is a sense of well-being.
There is a sense of
well-being, there's a presence,
there's very healthy--
mind is very healthy--
and without condition,
you feel good.
Without condition you feel good.
You don't need always needing
something's making me happy--
always searching.
But if your mind is really
comfortable, fundamentally
comfortable, it's not
like just comfortable
come from some conditions.
You went to talk to someone
that makes you feel comfortable,
or you eat something, that's
called conditional happiness.
Conditional happiness
always recharge each time.
Sometimes we are dependent
on conditional happiness.
And then most times
condition of happiness
is called instant gratification,
like coffee, drinking coffee.
Drinking coffee, immediately
you're very good,
and then a few hours later,
then it's finished that energy.
Then external
condition or happiness
is a very instant gratification,
and then it disappears.
But unconditional happiness
is always within you.
What that means, your mind
is some degree pristine.
You feel comfortable
all the time,
especially after
you do meditation.
After your meditation,
your mind is comfortable,
and then you talk
to other people
who are very comfortable.
Just at your office, always
you go walking cities, towns,
they're very comfortable
because there's
no uncomfortable thoughts,
because the reason is
fear comes from your thoughts.
The more you have thoughts, this
and that, positive, negative,
the more you have fearful.
The more you have thoughts,
the more you have anxiety.
the more you have stress.
Therefore, doing the meditation,
all thoughts are subside.
When your thoughts are
subside, fear subsides.
And because fear is to
related to your own thoughts,
then your thoughts are
subside, your anger subsides.
Your thoughts subside,
everything subsides.
And then one day,
all subsides, they
call it the fundamental peace.
The true peace comes from with
your access of pristine mind.
Therefore, unconditional
happiness means--
for example, my body is healthy.
When my body is healthy, I
feel good no matter what--
because my body is healthy,
therefore I feel good.
Similar, when your
mind is pristine,
you feel good no matter what.
Similar.
Physically you need a
healthy mind, healthy body,
but mentally you
need a pristine mind.
The more your mind is polluted,
the more you are uncomfortable.
Really, people
are uncomfortable,
the reason is, their mind
is polluted, distorted.
A distorted mind is not that
happy, not that content.
Therefore, usually if you
have a distorted mind,
then there is war between
your body and mind.
Body, mind really
criticizes body.
Mind says, body, you're ugly,
and you're fat, you're old,
you're bald, you have no hair,
you are not clean in mind.
Mind always criticizes
body, and that's
the reason the
body is very sick,
because mind between
there's war, body and mind.
And then the body's sick.
Then when body is sick,
then mind is unhappy,
and mind is stressed
because of your body.
There is war between body
and mind that's going on,
and that really
impacts people's life,
and impacts people's stress,
impacts relationships,
impacts their health.
But when your mind is
pristine, the war ends.
When your mind is
pristine, and then
the body and mind is united.
They call yoga-- you
know what yoga means?
Union of body and mind.
It means when your mind is
pristine, then your mind says--
hugs your body.
It says, I like you.
I love you.
Your mind loves body,
body loves mind.
There's union.
There's harmony experience,
because all the symptoms
or thoughts, projections
and negative thoughts,
created between body and mind.
When negative
thoughts disappear,
body, mind completely
come together.
As Body and mind
come together, and I
think that's the
most beautiful thing.
Say, what is really--
your body and mind
is same direction,
they're opposite direction.
Body goes that, mind goes that.
The conflict between most
every personal problems
come from that.
Stress, anxiety, fear--
all these things.
When your mind and body
are joined together,
then they're called happiness.
Joy, healthy living,
success, enlightenment.
Everything comes
from there, therefore
in order to have body
and mind come together,
I think you need to
have pristine mind.
Pristine mind is the
number one solution.
I like to talk about this.
How do you do it happened?
Let's say, first they call
realization pristine mind.
Realization pristine mind--
I mean, pristine mind means--
this is my meditation
introduction.
You see this?
Globe.
Fog globe.
Only San Francisco has it.
Only snow globe is different.
And you see this
globe very clearly.
It's pristine quality.
That's real.
This is natural condition mind.
It's like this.
When human mind is very
calm, relaxed, happy.
And then it's like this.
It's very pristine quality.
It's a very, very natural
condition like that.
This is really a human
mind is like that.
Let's say when
you're upset, you're
thinking something negative--
someone doing
something negative--
you're thinking about
that, what happens?
You see?
Everything's distorted.
You cannot see the
Golden Gate Bridge here.
The Golden Gate
Bridge disappeared.
Now everything's polluted.
The more you shake,
the more you pollute.
And similarly, the more you
think, the problem you have,
the more your mind is distorted,
and the more your mind
is polluted.
And then, what it's really
like when you're angry,
your mind is like this.
When you're sad, your
mind is like this.
When you stress, your
When you have any
other mental events,
your mind is like this,
because while you're like that,
we call pollute mind--
mind is pollute.
How do you resolve that?
The more you continue to
shake, you continue like that.
Similarly, some problem
occurs, and then you think
and continually, then
continually like that.
How do you resolve that?
Meditation introduction
says, don't follow past,
don't anticipate the
future, stay present.
Leave your mind alone.
Let's leave this alone.
What happens?
You see?
Slowly, slowly going.
Leave mind alone.
Don't follow past.
Don't anticipate any future.
Stay present moment.
Leave your mind alone.
You see, when you
leave your mind alone,
not going after the conditions,
this has become clear,
same as mind has become
more clear, clear,
and then your mind
has become pristine.
If you do meditation,
for example,
someone says I'm angry,
I'm very stressed.
What do I do?
What you do is--
when you stress--
don't follow past.
Don't anticipate future.
Stay present moment.
Leave your mind alone.
And then stay
there five minutes,
and slowly, slowly,
the stress energy
free and then dissolve, because
they're not anywhere your mind.
They are conditional.
Stress is conditional.
It does not exist in your
mind, because that's really--
mind is pristine.
And same as your anger.
When you're angry, how do
you really manage your anger?
Don't follow past.
Don't anticipate any future.
Stay present moment.
Leave your mind alone.
And then your anger
and that energy
fade away, because
they're conditional.
I just put this book,
and everything--
I put this book everything
how to practice,
how do your mind become
clear, how do you really
enjoy in a pristine mind.
And also, enjoy means, like--
I think this is very important--
the other is, one way,
meditation clarifies your mind.
The other is, you want
to expand you enjoy,
and satisfaction,
the happiness--
what you need to do is you
need to clear your mind.
When you clear your mind,
you enjoy everything.
You enjoy-- you know--
people go somewhere and
you can do same thing.
I was married
young, for example.
Younger time, I
just always enjoyed
do something,
entertaining things.
But when you're
getting old, everything
is same old, same old.
Then, [INAUDIBLE], what I do--
my secret to happiness is, I did
meditation maybe 20 minutes--
pristine mind
meditation, 20 minutes--
that's really given me whole
day-- today, tomorrow--
my mind is--
I can enjoy
everything after that.
It's not a conditions.
Conditions are always there,
but mind is the problem-- not
enjoy, not appreciate.
But you have the best
mind, you enjoy everything.
There's a quote here, if you
found happiness within you,
you've found
happiness everywhere.
It means your mind
is comfortable.
You have unconditional
happiness,
the conditional happiness much
more powerful-- double, triple.
Let's say, your
mind is complicated,
you'll never find
happiness anywhere,
because mind is unappreciated,
because happiness,
and joy, good connections,
relationships,
mainly depend how much you
have a beautiful mind--
I mean, very clear mind.
I think there's really
between connection, clear mind
and happiness, and distorted
mind and happiness.
When your mind is polluted,
definitely there's
unhappiness, stress.
And when your mind is clear,
there's happiness and joy.
You can tell that.
For example, when you say,
today is a beautiful day.
I'm very happy.
You look at that moment.
You see your mind is
clear at that moment.
You see that, everybody.
Say, today I'm angry, stress.
You see that moment,
your mind is polluted.
The pollution mind is connected
with unhappiness, stress,
all these things,
and pristine mind
is connected with
happiness and joy.
You know how to
connect other people.
You're more productive
for the world.
You're more fearless.
And I think those really are
the benefits about practice
of pristine mind, therefore I
don't have much time to right
now.
I think we have
questions, answers.
And I think you can do
this meditation, everybody,
because everybody has a duty
to clear out their mind.
Once your mind is clear,
everything is straight forward.
And that really, really we need.
The world is so much
developed right now,
external conditions are so good,
but if you don't have that kind
mind-- if you don't have--
our mind's more
distorted than before.
Our mind is more polluted.
And I think now is time
to clean our human mind.
And then we can factor
more external world,
and we can bring more happiness,
fulfillment, and therefore
I think that's number one.
And I think therefore I want
to say briefly, and two things,
the meditation can say, pristine
mind meditation can change
your perception, because if
you change your perception,
you change your world,
and therefore changing
our perception--
what that means--
the more you
meditate, the more you
realize that your
mind is pristine.
Oh yes, I can't believe--
I never noticed before,
because I never paid attention.
Now I see my mind is pristine.
And then you realize
second time, oh, yeah--
my thoughts, emotions,
stress, they're not me.
They're just mental events.
They're no different
than that cloud.
The clouds are just there
because conditions are there.
When the clouds disappear,
they're just gone.
My happiness, sadness,
anger, all these things,
are just like that cloud, and
the meditators realize that.
They call it change
your perception,
and they change
your experiences.
I want to say a few
things, and then I
think now I want to have some--
anybody have any
questions, I want
to have a question
and answer session.
They want to do me that soon.
That's very good.
And everyone has questions,
please raise your hands.
AUDIENCE: In the
mindfulness tradition,
there are different
kinds of meditation.
There's focus on
the breath, there's
open awareness, and
the transcendental,
there's a focus on a mantra.
So, is this form of meditation
different from any of those?
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Good question.
Yes.
[INAUDIBLE] meditations
are a goal sometimes.
There's two different
kinds of meditations.
One is object based
meditation, and the other
is objectless meditation.
Object based meditation means
your focus mantra and breath,
and that's really called--
Buddha says that when you
do go into slowly, slowly,
first [INAUDIBLE]
meditation, the goal
is calming the mind down.
Calming the mind down, this is.
And once you calm the
mind down, then slowly,
slowly journey into
slowly pristine mind.
That's traditionally do that.
First, do the focus mantra,
focus on the breath,
and when your mind is calmed
down, then what do you do?
What do you do when your
mind is calmed down?
And then it's leave
your mind alone.
After that-- until
you are not calm,
try to make your
mind calm, relaxed.
And then once your
mind is calmed down,
then don't rock the boat.
Don't rock the boat.
Just sit with that.
The more you sit with calmness--
and then that means you'll
leave your mind alone.
First, you need focus.
Maybe someone don't how to do
that, maybe you focus breath,
and also focus mantra.
This tradition is
called [INAUDIBLE],
preparations of pristine mind.
And then, once you know how to--
you have capable
watching the breath,
or you have mantra
many years, and then
you do the pristine mind,
going that direction.
Or some people go--
they're able to directly.
There are different methods.
For example,
mindfulness, the goal
is totally calming
your mind down.
And they want to
talk about, usually
traditionally, calm your
mind down, feel very peace,
and tranquil--
tranquility is the main focus.
And then you want
to go beyond that,
then you focus pristine mind.
And the pristine mind is then--
go to deep more.
First, focus object--
external object.
Breath is external object.
Mantra is external object.
When you talk about
pristine mind, you focus.
Just leave conditions out.
Just go more deep dive into--
deep into your awareness.
And then that's called
pristine mind meditation.
Traditionally, this is
called objectless meditation.
There's no object focus.
For example, an
airplane in the sky.
Airplane in sky.
First thing you need
to use a runway.
Without a runway, you
cannot fly in the sky.
But using the runway, then you
fly and continue into the sky.
Similar, first, people don't
know how to calm their mind.
They're using breath.
And then that's runway.
Take into the deep journey
your aware pristine mind.
And then runway and
mantra is focus.
Sometimes sounds,
like water sounds.
Focus that.
These things give
you tranquility.
Once your mind is calmed
down, then what do you do?
Leave your mind alone, then
continue doing journey.
And then don't focus
external conditions.
Then it's just only in.
When you airplane
in the sky, just
going to continue into the sky.
There's nothing
to do the runway.
Similarly, when you're
deep into the awareness,
there's nothing to do
with the breath or mantra.
All these things are
beginnings, they do,
and one is mantra,
and breath, they're
called object based
meditation, and pristine mind
is objectless meditation,
and that's the next step.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You
talked a little bit
about conditional happiness,
and how having a clear mind,
it will lead to
unconditional happiness.
Sometimes it feels
like I'm, like--
I want to go sit, because I
feel like I'm going to be happy,
and it feels I'm kind
of grasping for that,
or I'm turning the practice
into a conditional form
of happiness.
Can you give any tips
on how to avoid that?
ORGYEN CHOWANG: It's no problem.
You can-- say I
wanted to do practice,
and that's normal as anything.
But I think the main thing is,
make sure your mind is really
doing the meditation properly.
When you meditation
properly, you do it,
and everything is take care.
But I think the number one
is, when you do meditation,
it doesn't matter how you--
you need to do something,
say, I need to do meditation.
That's, I think-- we need that
inspiration, that motivation.
Without that motivation,
you never do meditation.
Therefore we need to do that
inspiration, that aspiration.
Do I want to do meditation?
And that enthusiasm, very much.
And then, depend what
kind of meditation.
People ask me, can
you fix my meditation?
But I ask first, I say, what
kind of meditation do you do?
And what are your goals?
When you do your exercise, we
know clear what are our goals.
Doing exercises, go to gym,
you want a clear, healthy body,
and losing weight, therefore
you're going to exercise.
Why people doing meditation?
You need to know
what the goal is.
The goal is vanishing
negative thoughts, emotions.
Mind becomes clear,
tranquil, pristine.
That's your goal.
I think, then you have
that experience or not,
and if not, then you're
not doing properly,
maybe you need to find
out how do you do that.
And then yes, then you're
going to reach your goals,
and therefore make sure your
mind is some degree pristine,
and some degree
clear, and tranquil.
And tranquil means [INAUDIBLE]
very passive, but tranquil
means there's energy.
For example, when you're
healthy, there's the energy.
Very healthy, there's energy.
Your healthy body
has lots of energy.
Similar, when your
mind is tranquil,
there's lots of vibrant energy.
It's not like, oh, I'm
[INAUDIBLE]-- it's peace--
it's not like that.
It's a very strong energy.
Tranquility, sense
of well-being,
and clear mind is so
strong presence there,
therefore make
sure that's there.
I think you can--
it's very good.
Therefore, I want
to mention, if you
have unconditional happiness,
and the conditional happiness
is double, triple this is.
Say you go on vacation.
Vacation is, let's say,
conditional happiness.
And your mind is
calm, and tranquil,
but you enjoy more vacation.
But your mind is turbulent,
complicated, polluted,
so you don't much
enjoy the vacation.
Therefore, how much
enjoy external conditions
depend on how much you
have a comfortable mind?
Therefore that is
unconditional happiness.
I don't know why human beings
are not focused on that.
You understand why?
Because everything is
obsessed with the conditions,
but conditions only we
need get 30% happiness.
I know, the more richer you are,
the more you are stressed for.
The more famous you are,
the more you stress.
There are so many--
any time, each year, one
musician [INAUDIBLE] die.
Always we hear each year, like
Michael Jackson's most famous
rock star, but he
died with drugs.
He's numbing his mind.
In order for you to
enjoy conditions,
you need to have the right mind.
If you don't have right
mind, you never enjoy life.
Conditions-- they are
for life, enlightenment,
and they all come from you
have the right mindset,
and pristine mind is key
to success this world,
and more effective.
And also, I just have experience
training many people to--
high tech companies,
other place they work--
and they tell me
totally different
when they have
meditated, because they
have less fearful, there's
no anxiety, stress,
they can talk to other
people without fear.
I think my own
experience, for example,
I go around to many
different groups.
When my mind is self-conscious,
I cannot connect to people,
but when my mind to some degree
pristine, I can connect people,
even I never met, because
the thoughts only disconnect
the people.
All thoughts of
self-consciousness, hesitation,
judgement is disappear.
You can't stress
for this connection.
I think that's a really
unconditional happiness.
And when you have
unconditional happiness,
the conditional happiness is
much powerful, more last long.
I think that's really
universal, also
understanding when your mind
is really such a good place.
AUDIENCE: I like that you
said that the pristine mind is
like that--
the goal.
And you gave us, I
think, the four paths.
It seems like there's a lot
of freedom there you have.
Don't look to the past,
don't look to the future,
be in the moment--
I'm not using the exact
words-- and also--
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Leave your mind.
AUDIENCE: --don't
follow the mind.
And it sounds very
good, a lot of freedom,
and it sounds so good.
My question is, is this
very open so that we can--
like, you're not
necessarily saying
you have to do a
mantra meditation,
or this kind of meditation.
There's a lot of freedom
there, as long as we're
sticking to those steps,
we can actually simply
get to that pristine mind?
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: I can do walking,
I can do my own meditation.
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Yeah.
Good question.
For example, when
you meditate, you
need two things
you are familiar.
One is, meditation
is repetition,
like when you go
to exercise-- gym
every day-- you do the same
thing, then losing weight.
[INAUDIBLE]
Similarly, when you meditate,
two things you're learning.
One is, remain in
present moment.
That's your learning.
You don't do today,
today meditate.
Let's say you begin today, and
then you stay present moment,
but your mind is chaos.
You cannot do.
And next time you
repeat that again.
Next time-- one, two,
three, four, five days--
five days later-- and,
yeah, I can little bit
much better than I can
stay present moment.
I have ability to stay
present moment one minute.
You have ability.
You have ability one
minute stay present.
And then you say, I gained
that maybe one week.
And next, maybe, two
weeks after, and you
do more meditation.
I have five minutes, I have the
ability to stay present moment.
If you have the ability to stay
present moment five minutes,
definitely your mind is
clear that five minutes.
And then I'll say,
I have that ability,
then slowly, slowly,
you are learning,
leave your mind alone.
We don't know how to do that.
Human beings, the mind is chaos.
But the more you meditate
and try to do, maybe one--
let's say today you start.
One month later, you're able
to leave your mind alone.
If you do these two things--
if you stay present moment
awareness, leave
your mind alone,
definitely you
have pristine mind.
Because if you do that,
all thoughts-- emotions--
are dissipated.
They're conditional.
Leave your mind alone,
[INAUDIBLE] you're angry,
there's no way.
You leave your mind
alone, you are stressed.
No.
If you do these two things--
stay present moment and
leave your mind alone--
and then your mind is
clear, because all thoughts,
emotions--
they're conditional mind.
They disappear.
And that's you
learning, like exercise.
And then gradually you occur.
It's not overnight.
It's not one workout.
You have the book.
There's two guided
meditations this book.
And one is second part
one guided meditation,
then other is third part.
There's another
guided meditation.
Two guided meditations.
Also, there's audio book.
That's very easy to do.
There's guided meditation
directly take you
into this pristine mind.
And then it's just repeat.
Meditation-- people think
they can do meditation--
but no.
First, you learn meditation,
then you meditate.
Like first you learn to
drive, then you drive.
First, you say-- first
you are not meditating,
first you're just
learning meditation.
After you learn how do
you stay present moment,
you leave your mind
alone, and then you
know how then you do that.
And that really, really--
people tell me their mind is
chaos, like all over the place.
That's normal beginners.
Don't discourage.
Beginner's mind is always chaos.
That's normal.
Even if thoughts
occur, that's normal,
but you come back
present moment.
If you're watching breath,
stay with the breath,
and you have the ability leave
your mind alone, you do that.
And then, naturally, our
thoughts, emotions subside.
The more you do that, the
more your mind is 70% clear.
And even if you are not a
meditate at that moment,
because gradually--
I think a percentage
is a very good.
Percentage.
Let's say my mind is 20% clear,
then it's my mind is 40% clear,
then it's mind is 70% clear.
I like percentage works,
because that's a reality.
And that really means you
need familiar with how
do you stay present moment, how
do you leave your mind alone.
These two things
can really, if you
are able to do that,
you have the ability to,
the meditators said they
have the ability to do that.
For example, someone do
the meditation one year,
that means--
it's not like, oh, they're
meditating sometimes
go room, come back,
there's your same person.
No.
You need to gain some ability.
What kind of ability
should you gain?
You have stay present
moment without distracting.
You have that ability, and
that's a result of meditation.
You can leave your mind
alone when you are upset.
When you leave your
mind-- when you're upset,
you leave your mind alone,
then everything dissolves.
You have that kind of ability,
it's the result of meditation.
Therefore, two things you focus.
Just stay present moment,
leave your mind alone.
Just focus that, and then
I think you can do that.
AUDIENCE: So, does that mean
that if you are meditating
properly, then you don't have
any thoughts in your mind?
ORGYEN CHOWANG: You want or not?
AUDIENCE: I mean, leaving
your mine a little.
ORGYEN CHOWANG: Doing the
meditation, and it's not--
depends.
For example, let's say
doing the meditation,
let's say, 20 minutes
you're doing the meditation.
The last thoughts
are more good--
last thoughts--
because even if--
someone's meditation-- even
a good meditation-- maybe
70% mind is pristine calm, but
you have still 20% [INAUDIBLE].
Let's say someone's yelling.
Oh, there's someone yelling.
Or I say, what time is it?
That's normal.
It's not like-- for
example, give you sky.
Overcast sky is not problematic,
but little bit clouds
are not big deal.
Here there are
clouds, no big deal.
Hazy skies, it's no problem.
When you're meditating,
most meditation
is a hazy mind state, because
hazy mind means you can aware,
but still you have
small, mental events.
And that's really normal,
therefore thoughts occur during
the meditation normal,
but our overcast isn't--
you cannot meditate.
Your mind is overcast, thoughts,
emotions, therefore first you
need work up overcast mind.
When you overcast, mind
is no longer overcast.
I think hazy mind is no problem.
Our meditation is
almost hazy mind.
There are some clear, same time
there some thoughts, therefore
there are five different skies--
stormy sky, there's
thunder lightning sky,
there's raining sky,
there's cloudy sky,
and there's clear sky.
There's pristine sky.
Five different skies.
Same is same different kind
of minds, very overcast mind,
and then there's rainy mind,
and there's cloudy mind,
then there's hazy mind, and
clear mind, and pristine mind.
They all just go to the
human mind that way,
and therefore thoughts
and no problem
you do in the meditation.
You lost into your present
moment, then it's problem.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, what is
the difference between a clear
mind and a pristine mind?
I wasn't sure I
understood that part.
Is there some-- are
you saying we'll just
reach that point eventually?
ORGYEN CHOWANG: I
think clear means--
you know, clear is relative,
and pristine is not relative.
Pristine is the
high quality one.
Clear means-- someone says this
maybe clear, maybe subtly still
not clear.
Maybe still there
something's going on.
Exactly similar, I think
they're a little bit different.
Pristine and clear, actually
they're two different words.
I think clear means
you see clearly.
Pristine means the high quality.
It's very natural
and unfabricated.
I think high quality
is the pristine.
Clear water and pristine water
is a little bit different.
You water is clear.
Still, maybe there is something.
But pristine water
means fabulous water.
Similarly, pristine
mind and clear mind--
but pristine mind is the
natural, unfabricated original
mind--
is pristine mind.
AUDIENCE: So, is there
something beyond pristine mind,
or is that the final goal?
ORGYEN CHOWANG:
That's the final goal.
For example, human bodies--
the highest quality of health.
Very normal.
Similarly, the highest
goal is pristine mind.
When you have
pristine mind, every--
[INAUDIBLE]
They say, all
thoughts, emotions,
experiences take that
quality, pristine quality.
This is your mind
is polluted, then
every thoughts,
emotions are polluted,
and that's really the reality.
That's really reality.
That happens.
SPEAKER 1: And thank you, again.
[APPLAUSE]